hello everyone I just got back from the
gym so you know I'm feeling pretty good
thought I had to do another chest video
and this game it was requested a lot of
times here on my channel so I decided to
do it it's a grandmaster Maurice Ashley
everyone knows who grandmaster Maurice
Ashley is is playing against Wilson the
hustler it's it's a game from the Tim
Ferriss documentary one small part of it
I will put a link in the description
below probably most of you have already
seen this video but those of you who
haven't it's an amazing video and it
features one move by Wilson the hustler
that could have been the greatest move
ever pulled off in chess history but
I'll show you this this in the game so
let's see this Wilson the hustler has
the white pieces and he goes for b4
already hustling from the very first
meal this is the Polish opening we have
E 5 by Maurice and a 3 now the Booga
attack I did a not a video but I did the
one game where Bobby Flay Bobby Fischer
played against this and I told you that
if Bishop to b2 is played then you can
freely simply capture this pawn on b4
and when Bishop capture simply play
Knight f6 you already have two pieces in
the game you're ready to castle and the
white hasn't even started so don't don't
get confused if someone plays b4 against
you so after E 5 a3 by Wilson the booga
attack a knight to f6 now Bishop to b2
attacking the e5 pawn d6 Maurice defends
it be three we have Bishop to e7
and knights to D - Maurice castles we
have an idea G to F 3 a 5 now breaking
that nice a a 3 B 4 pawn structure rook
to be won by Wilson 8 capture some
before a capture some b4 and Knight to
c6 attacking that b4 pawn c3 defending
the pawn and rook to e8 we have E for
now and if you look at this position
it's Wilson doesn't really have much to
show for he has this weird pawn
structure he has a blog Bishop on b2 he
has a rook and b1 that isn't really
doing anything and he still has the
castle by playing Bishop to e2
the Maurice already has the these
Knights placed on very nice squares the
bishop is ready to jump into the game
the rook is controlling the entire a
file so it's a good position for black
Bishop to g4 by Maurice that's also a
principled move you should always get
your pieces as deeper into the position
as you can
Bishop to e2 and now Bishop to f8
Maurice is now allowing this rook to
control the e5 pawn and preparing to
push d5 Wilson castles and d5 now h3
kicking the bishop bishop to h5 now he
capture Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 and
this is the first critical moment of the
game but it's not the move I was talking
about that will come a bit later here
Maurice has a better position but Wilson
has a couple of moves that will allow
him to you know to continue the game for
example be 594 is a decent move g3
probably the best move controlling the
DF for square not allowing this d5
Knight to jump to f4 but what some place
the knight to h2 and it's a really weird
for for a chess hustler at least in my
opinion I've never played against one to
miss such a simple tactic Bishop
captures Ani to mine by Maurice Queen
captures and now Knight to f4 and that's
why the g3 move was essential now the
night is attacking both Queen and now
there's a double attack on the d3 pawn
the Queen from d8 is also attacking the
d3 pawn queen to f3 getting the Queen to
safety and now simply Queen captures on
d3 Maurice grab a pawn and this is
perfectly enough for him to win the game
he's the Grandmaster after all Queen
captures on d3 Knight character son b3
and we had Knight to f3 now he retreats
the knight to f3 Maurice immediately
activates the rook on the second rank
now there's a double attack on the b2
Bishop Bishop to c1 and here we have e 4
and when Wilson the hostler saw this
efore move he knew that now he's
definitely going to lose the game as the
knight and v2 is protected by the bishop
and c1 and the knight on f3 so by
playing efore
Maurice gets rid of one defender of the
night Andy - he will next capture the
second defender and will simply grab the
free piece that is the night on D - so
Wilson played night before
Maurice captured the knight on d4 and
this is the moment this is moved 2022
and this is where the magic happens here
Wilson tried this Wilson removed this
Knight from the board then he grabbed
this pawn and while while moving on to
place the pawn on d4 he also grabbed the
night that was on d3 and he placed the
night that was on d3 on d4 and wanted to
grab the other night as well with the
pawn so Maurice was like what is this
and he actually managed to get those
nights he grabbed one night and imagined
the other night of the board but Maurice
quickly grabbed at night and placed it
back on d3 and it really it really shook
Wilson The Hustler that he wasn't able
to pull this off but if he managed to
pull it off you know in front of cameras
and audience it would it would truly be
one of the the greatest moves ever
played in chess but now comes tonight
captures on c1 removing the defender of
the d2 Knight rook captures and rook
captures on d2 rock capture Sun c7 this
is now a completely winning position for
black as your upper piece you have a
bishop white doesn't rock after Sundy
for rock after Sun b7 rook captures on
b4 rook captures Bishop captures and now
the any any other player was probably
surrender disposition but Wilson The
Hustler hopes hope for hopes for some
hustling chances so rook to be one
attacking the bishop Bishop to c5 Wilson
also imagined that he would maybe win
the game on time against no reason but
Maurice was actually way up on time so
rough to see one going after the bishop
again rook to e5 and for those of maybe
for beginners this will be an
interesting example how to win a winning
endgame
so King to f1 and now f5 so the easiest
way to win the same game is to simply
bring the King as deep into the
as you can you have to play with your
King in the endgame so King to be 2 now
g5g three King comes into the game King
f7 rugby one now rook to e7 and not
allowing any checks rugby 7 rock to be
five and now rook to c7 and not allowing
white any counter play whatsoever the
King is now free to enter the center of
the board
King back to F one King e6 King e2 now
King to d5 rugby one rook to a7
preparing the rook to come to the second
rank Ruby one now Bishop to d4 you can
see that the bishop and the pawn are
controlling all of the squares in front
of the White King so the King is pretty
much useless their King to f1 rook to a2
now cutting off the King even further
the King is now unable to enter even D 2
square also the threat is rook captures
an f2 winning the game immediately saw
Wilson tried f4 e captures an f3 on
Poisson was played and Wilson simply
played rook captures skin captures and
as there was really nothing else to do
here in this position Wilson The Hustler
resigned the game so yeah that's the
game it's pretty much one of the most
famous games on the entire internet
played between Wilson The Hustler and
more Grandmaster Maurice Ashley I do
hope you enjoyed it as a lot of you have
requested to see this game I didn't
really have a hard time because a lot of
people in the comments already put the
PG in of the game in the comments so i
hope i hope they wrote it correctly so
yeah i would like to thank a tile
fulfillment and I'm sorry in the
previous video I instead of your name I
just wrote Merry Christmas in Spanish
because I thought that was actually your
name so I I'm sorry about that
Joseph Thornton hermano cannot see
McHale hildebrand and Nick can't guess
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon and like I said
check out the the video with the
original footage there will be
link in the description below thank you
and I will see you soon